[Music]
from an action-packed sci-fi adventure
to a tweet modern take on a classic
sitcom these are the best TV shows of
2018 throw some popcorn in the microwave
and dig out your binge-watching
sweatpants because we're diving in who
would have guessed it would take a
cartoon about a foul-mouthed
anthropomorphic horse to really nail the
traits and tribulations of fame
depression and generation or trauma
basically Bojack horseman has been a
revelation balancing wits humor and
plenty of madcap charm with a deep
emphasis on the way sadness permeates
well everything and even for those
familiar with how brutally tragic and
then flinching the show can get season
five took Bojack horseman to new heights
you're here and I hate you but you're my
best friend and you need me plenty of
other shows of featured antihero leads
but Bojack never loses sight of the fact
that as titular lead crappier actions
remain forever present and the weight of
his awful actions are hiding just below
the surface season 5 brought all that
subtext directly to the forefront as
Bojack struggled to escape his past
mistakes even when confronting them
might be the only way he can ever
actually be free and beyond the weighty
subject matter season 5 was an ambitious
exercise from a show that thrives on
pushing the envelope for instance it
would have guests at one of the season's
highlights would be a 20-minute
monologue by Bojack performed with a
hypnotizing bittersweetness by actor
Will Arnett's Bojack has always been one
of the best shows on Netflix but season
5 cement of the show is one of the best
series on television period there have
been plenty of movies and television
shows about acting in Hollywood life but
no show has managed to capture the
unique strangeness of struggling actors
in Los Angeles quite like Barry the show
follows Bill Hader as Barry a hit man
who struggling with a growing sense of
ennui and finds his life changed when he
stumbles into an acting class and gets
bitten by the acting bug these are
professional actors and they're the real
deal and they say I got something what
follows is a hilariously dark comedy as
Barry struggles to leave his life of
crime behind to make it as an actor even
while former clients and the
manipulative mentor conspire to keep him
in their clutches
everything come back here and I'll kill
every single money turret Albury is
equally funny and ruthless about what it
means to make it in the City of Angels
Barry actually is a nice guy but he's
also a reluctant contract killer really
he just wants to follow his dreams like
many a young actor in Hollywood anyone
who's ever attended a friend's improv
class or been asked to look over a movie
script will find plenty to relate to in
Barry after coming out with a strong
start and a lot of positive reviews the
Marvel Netflix shows have faltered
somewhat over the years i infest scene
like a misfire almost immediately and a
better reviewed second season that
didn't manage to keep it from getting
cancelled a fate that was also suffered
by Luke Cage with all of this dour news
it would have been easy for daredevil
season 3 to come and go as silently as
the ninjas Matt Murdock fights but as it
turns out this batch of episodes came
out swinging and the new season is a
perfect reminder of why people were
excited about the Netflix Marvel shows
to begin with Charlie Cox returns as
Matt Murdock bringing all of his
considerable angst and moody charisma to
the four cogs had a lot to work with -
season three puts daredevil in just
about the worst position imaginable
grinding the hero down to paste just to
see if he can build himself back up it's
a thrilling season with jaw-dropping
action and some of the best acting on
television best of all Vincent D'Onofrio
returns as Wilson Fisk the charismatic
kingpin whose brutality is only matched
by his skill at manipulation I have made
many mistakes
and I accept the debt I'm been because
of them
despite Daredevils success on November
29th the Netflix announced the show
would be cancelled he has to hoping
Netflix is canceled Marvel shows
continued their heroics on some other
platform in the future after returning
to television for the first time in 20
years in 2005 Doctor Who we established
itself as a stylish sci-fi show for a
new audience still despite multiple show
runners and multiple actors playing the
eponymous doctor the next decade of
Doctor Who settled into a comfortable
rhythm an eccentric male lead on again
off again romances with various co-stars
callbacks to the original run and silly
science-fiction shenanigans no oh no
show but cook up a Papa Joe
that all changed in 2018 when for the
first time a woman took over as the
title character Jodi Whitaker's Turner
Seductor ended up being exactly the shot
in the arm that the show needed
coinciding nicely with new showrunner
Chris Chibnall tenure based on her web
series awkward black girl insecure
follows a fictionalized version of
creator and star Issa Rae as she
grapples of the complexities of black
life a feminism and millennial culture
in securest whip-smart about portraying
complicated issues with nuanced and
genuine humor it's easily one of the
funniest shows on television and poke to
the brim with wit and the motion season
3 hasn't just kept up the show's hot
streak either it's arguably the best yet
Michael and/or Brodeur a Boston Globe
writes that insecure has never felt more
confident and it's hard to disagree even
three seasons deep into the show Ray's
abilities as a writer showrunner
producer and performer have never been
so obviously apparent insecure keeps
growing improving and changing like few
other shows and season 3 was a perfect
reminder that you should be making it
appointment television The Haunting of
Hill House is horror at its best
simultaneously terrifying and thrilling
while also dealing with the emotional
core that should be at the center of
every horror movie that richness of
character has led to some reviews
calling Hill House a drama with ghosts
or like this is us wrapped in a gothic
ghost story
make no mistake Hill House is absolutely
terrifying
director showrunner Mike Flanagan
showcases all the technical brilliance
that made oculus and Gerald's games so
profoundly scary and through it all he
never loses sight of the fact that the
ghosts are away for the audience to
connect to the crane family's trauma
it's just that you know they're also
scary as hell fans of classic 90s
sitcoms rejoiced when ABC announced that
they greenlit a revival of Roseanne for
many viewers the show had earned its
place in history alongside Chiu's
Frasier and other classic television
comedies unfortunately the jubilation
didn't last long
just a couple months after the new
series premiered star Roseanne Barr
tweeted out a racist statement and
almost immediately led to the show's
cancellation luckily even though he
shared a name with its star Roseanne was
never just about Roseanne the creative
talent behind the show quickly pivoted
to making the Conners a continuation of
the fans favorite family - Roseanne of
course
whose character had died off-screen what
about when the casseroles run out what
if the person who died is the only one
who cooked and we keep telling people
were grieving until we figure out how to
feed ourselves critical reception to the
newly tweet show has been largely
positive with critics like Alan
Sepinwall of Rolling Stone writing there
are enough sturdy characters and
performances here to move on without her
and the premiere felt more focused some
many of the episodes from the spring
donald glover and his team had a lot to
live up to when the second season of
atlanta was announced the show's first
season firmly established it as one of
the most electrifying television series
in recent memory and the Glovers
performance has earned in season two of
Atlanta subtitle Robin season is as good
as you'd expect but it also showcases
other characters with a confidence that
you won't see on any other show Tate
dish
we work here yeah they got him no chase
policy the season was filled with
standout episodes highlighting the other
characters in the show like the
nightmarish Teddy Perkins which followed
Darius played by the Keith Stanfield
meeting a Michael jackson-esque musician
in an ominous mansion woods on the other
hand followed Bryan Tyrese Henry's owl
aka paperboy as he's haunted by the
downsides of his own fame and success
more than half of the season was
directed by hero Mariah
lovers longtime music video director and
mirai's expert visual sense and rich use
of surrealism has made Atlanta one of
the best-looking shows on television as
the prequel and sometimes kind of sequel
to Breaking Bad vertical Sol takes a bit
of a slower pace than its predecessor
but it's still prone to occasional
explosions of violence you're more
likely to see elaborate cons on the
vicious meth heads that populated
Breaking Bad but the underlying moral
decay and fantastic character writing is
even better Bob Odenkirk fills Jimmy
with such warmth and humanity that is
like watching a horror movie as he
slowly sinks into corruption losing his
last bits of morality in the process
even for a show as consistent as better
called soul season 4 was a victory lap
that took viewers closer to the events
of Breaking Bad and anyone really
expected and we couldn't be more excited
for what's to come much like a Greek
tragedy we already know that Jimmy is
destined for moral rot and the job of
managing a Cinnabon which sounds awesome
how can you not like Cinnabon the beauty
of the show is how much you don't want
it to happen DC's new take on a familiar
cast of Caped Crusader's Titans needed
just two glorious words to get fans
riled up sure Robin and the rest of the
titular team that like they just brought
out a hot topic but critics dig DC's
gritty reimagining of the young
superheroes for instance autumn the well
kelly at Newsweek wrote positively about
the show claiming Titans is the most
balanced superhero show out there
it's skillfully constructive narrative
Lee speaking and there's a surprising
amount of flavor beneath its
classification as a dark moody teen
drama
turns out there's more pleasure to be
had in Titans and watching Robin drop
the f-bomb HBO's True detective brought
cary fukunaga 'he's work to a mainstream
audience his keen eye for cinematography
was a key component of the show's season
one success
after that he released the beasts of no
nation which was met with similarly
positive critical acclaim
then he more or less disappeared for
three years before blazing back to the
small scream of maniac the wait was
worth it
starring Jonah Hill and Emma Stone as
patients in an experimental mental
health study and a retro futuristic
dystopia that beautifully shot maniac
jumps from genre to genre through Owen
and Annie's fantasies and Fukunaga keeps
the focus squarely on the difficulty of
living with mental illness and trauma
and the possibility of finding
connection and community despite or even
because of those issues of course you
make me happy you're only happy